whatever happens your commitment to
success should not weaken
that is what get you across so many
lines
in our life a lot of your insecurities
come from a lack of clarity
there is a law of thinking and we are
beginning
to learn about it and it is like a
computer
want to be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
[Music]
a life hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn to start
your morning
every day with these routines enjoy
okay let's kick it off with routine
number one be aware of your thoughts
with louise hay
the simple part that most people don't
understand
is that every thought we think in every
word we speak
is creating our future it's as though
our thoughts
go out into the universe and are
accepted
and brought back to us as experience
now that is a very simple thing but most
people don't get it they don't
understand it they've never heard it
before and they think it's ridiculous
but if you can really accept the fact
that every time you think a thought
and every time you speak a word you are
literally
painting your future making your dinner
whatever you want to call it you are
creating
and you're creating your own life
and this is simple but it's not
easy to accept but once you accept it
then you can start deliberately creating
what you want in your life
and you begin to be aware of what you
don't want in your life and how you are
contributing to it
now i think this has been around forever
but for
some reason in the last 20 years the
universe has wanted
this to go out among all the people or
all the people that are ready for it
see most of us just think they think
think think think think and we don't pay
any attention to what we're thinking
we're just doing it but that's something
you need to train yourself to do
to begin to train yourself to be aware
of what you're thinking
and and one of the ways to do that is to
periodically say to yourself what am i
thinking
would i like this thought to create my
life
would i like to have the experience that
this thought could bring to me
now it takes a while to do that but even
if we could begin on the smallest level
to be aware of our thinking we can start
to make changes
to begin with you start by doing what we
call
doing affirmations and that is making
positive statements about your life that
are positive and you do them
deliberately
you might do them in the morning you
might do them at noon you might do them
at night
you might do them you know twice a day
or whatever
but you do this and you let this become
a habit
and as you start to do them things will
begin to change maybe on a very small
level i call it getting the green lights
and the parking places
i mean they're not huge things in your
life it can be very nice when you get
three green lights in a row
and you're in a hurry doing an
affirmation is either writing it down
writing it on the wall or the mirror or
using a
you know just saying it what i like
people to do
is to stand in front of a mirror and do
their affirmations
because there's something very powerful
about looking in your own eyes
and getting and accepting yourself
or noticing that you reject yourself
when you're saying something positive
about yourself
so that would be a very beginning way to
start
say in the morning you get up in the
morning you go to the mirror and
this is a big one and it's hard for lots
of people
but you look in the mirror and i say and
say i love you
i really really love you
and to begin with that can be so hard
for people because they think of all the
things that they think are wrong with
them
but if you can start your day saying
that it's very powerful
remember i'd like to think the universe
is listening to everything you say
and everything you think and saying okay
you can get that
so then it starts to bring you in and
bring things into you
and i know this sounds fart fetch but
it's amazing how it works
you if you do a good general positive
statement for yourself
the universe will figure out how to
manifest that how to bring that about in
your life
so things could happen that you wouldn't
expect at all
but they will happen if you think of
doing
your positive affirmations is like
planting a seed in the ground
it's not necessarily true at the moment
but it is something you want to have
be true so you put the seed in
and you you you plant a seed and you
expect it to grow
or you maybe plant three seeds just in
case you expect them to grow
and you don't wait two days and then dig
in the earth and say what's happening
what's happening
you expect that thing to grow because
you know there's a law and a process
and the seed will grow if it is in the
right soil
and it has the right amount of moisture
making it really a habit
and doing it every day doing something
every morning when you wake up that's a
really good time
and another good time is when you go to
sleep at night
and and gratitude works a lot uh
if just being grateful for everything
the more
i always say the universe loves
gratitude the more you're grateful
for what the good is in your life
the more good you get to be grateful
about and it's it's like you know if
somebody gives you a present in your
or gives me a present and i say oh my
god i hate that color and it doesn't fit
and you know
that person will never give me another
present
but if you say oh it's wonderful and
thank you i really adore it it's great
that person is probably going to want to
buy you a present every time they see
something they think you would like
and it's like that with the universe the
universe loves gratitude
if you have very strong beliefs within
you
that you don't deserve good things in
your life
and a lot of people have that then there
can be delays
and sometimes people say well
affirmations don't work i've done
them but when they're doing for instance
prosperity affirmations
and they've done some prosperity
affirmations and they say it doesn't
work nothing's happening and i say well
all right
how many prosperity affirmations did you
do in a day
and they'll say three probably and they
say all right how many
poverty affirmations did you do this day
and that could be 300 depending on where
you're coming from
and what are is running through your
mind
see i have this one of my thoughts about
life
is that only good lies before me and
i've been saying this for
many years so it doesn't really matter
to me
what happens in life because i know it's
going to be good
you can't change your thoughts if you
don't know what your thoughts
are there is a law of thinking
and we are beginning to learn about it
and it is
like a computer if you have this
gorgeous computer put in front of you
and you don't know what to do with it
it's a piece
of junk but if you learn the language of
the computer
miracles happen
and that is what the law of thinking is
when you learn how it works
miracles happen what you think
and what you believe is what will come
true for you
your thoughts create your life
it's that simple and when we can get
that
we can make enormous changes routine
number two
seek clarity with brendan burchard human
beings
are a goal-directed species if
we don't have clarity on what we want
if we don't have clarity on who we are
if we don't have clarity on what our
intentions are in social relationships
it's it's unnerving to us
who's ever felt lost in life ever felt
lost in life
well if you ever felt lost in life you
know that
feeling it's coming from a lack a
often of clarity we'll talk about this
you just don't know
who you are what you're about what you
want anymore and and it's unsettling
when you lack clarity it's really
unsettling
you're like i i don't i don't know what
i'm about anymore and this is where
midlife crises come in
this is where the difficulties when you
get laid off
come in because you don't know what what
you're supposed to do that month anymore
or
when you retire from the thing and now
you don't know what to do with yourself
or the kids leave the house and your
role just changed from
parent to you know freedom
from something shifted in you and you
don't know what to do with this new
world anymore
well guess what's happening in the world
right now at a macro level
the world you know the world's in such
shifting times
that it can feel very uncertain for us
and that lack of clarity of how things
are going to turn out can really be
unnerving
a lot of your insecurities come from a
lack of clarity
a lack of clarity when we study the most
productive people in the world what we
call high performers
their first practice is to seek clarity
they're
always asking what what's important to
me here
what's the best next right action of
integrity
what do i really want what would feel
fulfilling here
they're asking more questions so they're
getting more clarity
all right my friend evan carmichael's
book listen humans are built to serve
some people are built to serve the world
others
want to serve the 25 people closest to
them but in either case humans are built
to serve so if you're not happy right
now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
routine number three focus on your goals
with john assaraf
what i want you to imagine for a moment
is an archer
what does an archer do obviously they
get their equipment ready
but then they focus on a bullseye on
one spot specifically that they want
all of their attention and intention
to focus on so when you set a goal
for your health your wealth the
relationship that you want to have the
amount of money you want to make
how fast you want to pay off debt how
fast you want to buy your new home
how much money you want to put in your
child's bank account
for college when you set a specific
target
two things happen number one it gives
your
brain something to prime it with
and what i mean by prime it with is
basically something that you're telling
your brain
i want to focus on that show me
anything or everything that's going to
help me
find that goal also it cognitively
primes your brain to get you to start
taking action
when you do this one little thing look
at that goal
every day don't just write out that goal
or two or three or four goals
look at it every single day and as you
look at it what i want you to do
is i want you to say a simple
affirmation for
each one of your goals and the
affirmation i want you to say goes like
this
i'm so happy and so grateful
that and read out the goal so
that i've put three thousand dollars in
my savings account this month or
that i've now released five pounds of
weight or that
my wife and i having the best
relationship ever or that
my business is growing by 15
a quarter when you say i'm so grateful
and happy for the fact that
there's a part of the brain that doesn't
know the difference between something
that you close your eyes and imagine
something that's real that's happening
or something that you're reading
off of a piece of paper so the more you
focus on the goal read the affirmation
the better the instruction is for the
brain
to think it's already happened which
means it's going to get you to see
everything in line with that goal
it's going to get you to think about it
routine number four
commit to success with sad guru this
happened
in your school maybe later in your
university later in your work
it's happening to people maybe not
everyone but a whole lot of people
their commitment to success is weak
they want to succeed they will take
three steps then
something little interesting happens
here they will go away here
they'll go away there they'll go with it
hey i want to live
their commitment to success is weak
either situations around them in some
way
you know situations can impede you from
doing what you're doing very easily many
times it happens
to everyone but when this happens
people weaken their commitment for their
success
maybe physically they'll feel little
weak
they will weaken their commitment to
success
maybe their emotions slosh around a
little bit
they will weaken their commitment to
success
this is very important right now
however long it takes this
virus
you must come out of this successfully
that means you will stay alive that's an
important part
and commitment to staying alive
should not be slackened no matter what
happened somebody very
dear to us passed away all the more
important we must live
[Music]
people around us are all sick all the
more important we are healthy to take
care of the people around us
[Music]
so our commitment to success should not
weaken
because there is social drama going on
or physiological drama or psychological
drama whatever happens
your commitment to success should not
weaken
that is what get you across so many
lines
in our life so many barriers in our life
routine number five compound time with
ed mylett
why is a day only 24 hours i mean
if the average people in the world or
the majority of people have a 24-hour
day
why does it have to apply to you many
years ago i discovered have you ever had
a day where in four or five hours you
got more
in the first four or five hours done or
accomplished in your day
than you had in a normal day you ever
have a four or five hour window a six
hour window like they go i've got so
much done in these six
hours it's more than i get done in an
average day and what i found out was
max out elite performers people that
perform at the highest level
they get more done in a six hour window
than most people get done in a day and
here's why most people measure a day
by 24 hours so i started to think i was
young in business i was in my early 20s
and one of the things that was held
against me by other people is you're too
young to win
you don't have enough experience you
just haven't have enough days of
experience in your life enough days in
business to win i thought
well how can i fix that and here's how
you can fix that and i've adopted this
now for almost 30 years
i want the average people i compete
against to think they have a 24-hour day
my days are six days long so i want to
teach you the concept of running many
days
my day my first day is from 6 a.m to
noon every day that's a
full day for me so i try to get done a
full day's work from 6 a.m to noon
because i no longer have a 24 hour day
in my life i have a six hour day
and so a day to me is that measure of
time it altered the complete direction
of my life it transformed who i am
so now from 6 a.m to noon is a day
that's my first day
every single week 6 a.m to noon monday
morning and what happens in that 6 a.m
to noon
i see there's a mental thing we have i
have a whole day to get all these things
done
and so we stack and dictate and schedule
our day
over that 24-hour window of time you'd
be surprised if you shrunk that eight to
six hours
you can get the same things done in
those six hours you used to get done in
24
from noon to 6 pm is my second day and
in that second day
i fill it up with the with a full day's
worth of fun
memories meetings phone calls you name
it
meetings with my relationships in my
life in that six hour day
i pack out another day from noon to 6
p.m
i fill that day up and my third day is 6
p.m
to midnight and then that's 6 p.m to
midnight same thing my relationships my
meetings my phone calls my emails the
work i do
is a third day and so what happened was
when i was in my early 20s i went from
having three days
in the same window of time when the
average person had one and i started to
accomplish
triple what the average person was
accomplishing now once again
you stack up three days in 24 hours
over a week a month a year in just one
year
i end up with over a thousand days and
i'm competing against people only have
365.
think about the mind-blowing difference
could be in your life
if you ran many days the rest of your
life i'm telling you right now
that my days are six hours long you'll
be the the amount of work you can get
done the amount of compounding that will
take place in your life it's gonna blow
your mind
when you start looking at your schedule
day one is six am
to noon day two is noon to six p.m day 3
is 6 p.m to midnight
your whole existence is going to change
it'll be kind of fun in the beginning
you'll mess it up but you stack up a
week or two and you do that for a month
imagine that in one month getting 90
days
think about what would happen in your
life if in a month you had 90 days
and the rest of the world the average in
your life imagine that for a second
the rest of the world only had 30. and
you stacked that up over a year
or three years how different would your
life be and routine number six the last
one before a very special bonus clip
is push yourself more with tom bilyeu
it was about 15 years ago i had this
sense that i was stuck in the matrix
that my life could be something more but
i know how to make it more right and
part of that was
on a day when i wanted to stay in bed
when it was warm i did
uh and then time just feels like it's
getting away from you and you haven't
really identified that the the problem
was
that you didn't have something specific
enough to get you out of bed right you
weren't setting goals you didn't have a
vision you weren't
executing on your dreams you might be
dreaming like i was dreaming i've always
dreamed
uh for me ambition was never the problem
i was the most
ambitious laziest person you're ever
going to meet 15 years ago
and it was realizing wait just because
i'm lazy by nature doesn't mean i have
to be lazy in actuality like i can
actually get the discipline
to develop real drive to acquire those
skills so
when i met the guys that are now my
partners uh they put me
into a scenario where there was a very
real world
consequence both positive and negative
for living up to
the acquisition of skills so and and
that
environment that uh gladiator pit that i
ended up stepping into was the business
world
and the great thing is when you're no
longer an employee and it's your
business and everything you have is on
the line and if the business fails you
lose your house like
that that's real yeah it's real to you
in a way that it's not to an employee
right because
now there's a real consequence that goes
beyond well i have to look for another
job right this goes into
i could lose everything if i can't solve
this problem now that
can scare you away and keep you wanting
to be an employee where it's a little
bit safer
or that can be wildly motivating to you
and that was
interesting to me so i wanted to be able
to say the harder i work the better
result i get
and they gave me the opportunity to plug
into business where that became true
if i could solve these problems if i
could build a better product if i could
market it better whatever
that better results came and so there
was like now a connection between how
hard i work
the skills i acquire and the reward i
get and that that was all i needed
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and you just get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
gotta take action
but when you get motivated and then you
create a specific plan of action for
when and how you're gonna do it your
number jumps from 35
to 91 percent chance of following
through and when you commit to somebody
else
like posting down here in the comments
below that number jumps to 95
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so you
can follow through and i can celebrate
you you have to decide if you're going
to play scared
or play to win at the end of the day a
lot of our
business success just comes down to the
simple question one of the biggest
reasons why people don't
win don't achieve their goals don't
accomplish their mission is because
you've decided to play scared instead of
trying to play to win that's it in how
you approach
your business and how you approach every
problem that you're facing
playing scared means i need the perfect
plane playing scared means somebody
might copy my idea
playing scared means if i bring on this
employee maybe they leave me and go do
something else
right and they take my idea and they run
with it this that's playing scary
a lot of people live in place scared
mode and what it does is
prevent you from taking action you can't
start until you have the perfect plan
right i mean unless i have it all
figured out and have the perfect plan
with financing and the right team i
can't start because what if i
but if i screw up i can't hire somebody
until it's perfect because
what if they screw me over and they
leave and they'd start their own company
and take all my customers with me
uh you know i'm scared about the
competition what if they see what i'm
doing
and they catch on to it too soon and
then they go off and create it
and i'm stuck holding the bag having to
invest in this business and never
succeeding right it's like
and you play these mind games and you
never take action this is the problem
when you live your life through fear you
never make the right decision
you have to learn to play to win and and
i'm a recovering perfectionist
i understand that was my default mindset
i lost
the 40 million deal when i was 21
22 because i needed to have the perfect
plan
because i was afraid that i would go in
and i might get asked questions that i
didn't know how to
answer and so i put the brakes on
i pump the brakes instead of doing what
i need to do to get out there and
actually start creating
and so i'm still i'm still battling that
and every time i'm trying to
be perfect any time i catch it's like
okay let's go let's just go
go from idea to action make it happen
i look at my youtube channel as an
example and i look at my thumbnails
and we get a lot of credit and praise in
the industry for having
great thumbnails and we've done over
6 000 split tests it's something crazy
now
on thumbnails and titles and and trying
to find the best combination on youtube
and i still think we have a big
room for improvement a long way to go
and
yesterday we're launching last year we
launched 100 new split tests we're
launching
almost 100 new split tests a day that's
the goal that's our next benchmark
100 new split tests every single day to
test
faces colors fonts layouts formats all
of it to see how we can beat our own
thumbnails
and i have a public challenge that hey
i'll open it up here
if you think you can beat my thumbnails
let's go
i want you to beat my thumb i want you
to teach me how to make better
thumbnails i want it i want somebody to
beat my thumbnails
and as long as they're half decent you
know i'll run a split test against
my current version and i want you to win
i want you to win i want you to beat me
because if you can beat me then i can
apply
that strategy and hire you to go fix
ten thousand other thumbnails that i've
got on my channel
because that's playing the win that's
playing to
i don't care if i'm right i want to win
i want to find the person who's right i
want to get the best results
i want you to show me why my thumbnails
suck as opposed to
oh my gosh what if somebody has better
thumbnails and beats me
and then goes and starts their own
thumbnail business and then and then
works with all my competitors and then
puts me out of business because all my
competitors now
are crushing it and they're doing better
than me right that's that's losing
thinking
it's a waste of energy it's a waste of
time and it puts the brakes on all your
momentum
you're just scared and when you make
decisions
from a place of fear even though you
logically justify it right you'll find
great reasons all those reasons why
you're not doing the thing you want to
do they make total sense right that
makes sense
otherwise you wouldn't believe it if the
reason didn't make sense you wouldn't
believe it
so it makes sense why you're not doing
it but underneath is really just fear
underneath is just fear you're just
scared you're scared that it
won't work out you're scared that you
might lose money you're scared that
people might see you fail you're scared
you're scared so you pump the brakes and
you don't do the thing that you need to
do
you have to switch that mindset to plane
to win
you have to switch the mindset to say i
need to make this happen
today is important i'm tired of playing
small
i'm tired of sitting on my hands i'm
tired of waiting for other people
to give me permission and approval to do
this thing i'm tired of it
i've got a big mission i've got a big
heart i know i can do this and i'm ready
to go
right like the more you live in that
mindset
the more you're gonna win so how do you
do it how do you shift it how do you
start
playing to win instead of playing from
fear
a couple ideas first is whatever makes
you feel that way
have it more often in your life if these
videos do it for you it's why i'm trying
to create that
shot of espresso every morning for you
guys because if these videos do it for
you then good news i'm here every day
and if it's not these videos it's my
other videos i'm making videos every day
and
i'm pretty much on my channel so there's
lots of content and whatever if you hate
me great
uh forget evan go watch somebody else or
go read those books or go listen to
those podcasts but
whatever the thing is it makes you feel
bold fired up
powered up ready to go i'm tired of
playing small whatever that is for you
put it in your daily
it's not enough to have it randomly come
across your youtube feed
you have to set aside time for it every
day
because when you inject yourself with
that belief you've got the you've got
the heart you've got the talent you've
got the skills you can make it happen
you and the things that you don't know
how to do you can figure out the biggest
problem is you just don't have the
belief
so whatever gives you that belief to
switch you from playing from fear to
playing to win
is the thing that has to be part of your
daily routine
[Music]
if you want to know the morning routines
that will transform your life check out
the video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there every morning
in seal training my instructors who at
the time were all vietnam veterans
would show up in my barracks room and
the first thing they do is inspect my
bed
if you did it right